Marvel superhero with your vision powers
what would your name be Raven Baxter and
what my overall favorite thing about
being part of that so Raven would have
to be the camaraderie we had behind the
scenes we had such a fun time I don't
know how many cakes I've had in my face
and hair
all of the costumes we had and the fact
that we were a family and it just goes
to show we were because a lot of the
crew hair and makeup team and everyone
came back for the installment of ravens
home the most outrageous outfit that
I've worn on that so Raven would have to
be the one where I was about to marry a
prince and I was in a red and golden
frock you know you gotta use words like
that when that outfit comes out it was a
frock and it was very interesting and
then there's also the one actually in
country cousins that was a black and
white and I used to wear a lot of jeans
suits like jeans with the top to me and
it was just crayons colored on the on
top of it that was what I died
[Music]
well Raven Baxter has changed she has
two kids they're twins
she has a job she's divorced from Devon
and she's a grown woman Raven Symone I
came out and I'm an artist I'm a painter
the favorite episode in general which
was actually the hardest to shoot would
be country cousins because I played a
grandmother of father and a baby and
myself and that was a lot of work but
that one turned out awesome
a cringe show only because I remember
the drama that it took to actually get
through it was Cory's birthday which was
with the dancing iguana and the snake
they didn't tell me I was gonna be
holding the snake I was actually scared
and I will forever be scarred that's
hard because she's had a lot of quotes
and lines I'm trying to really dig in
there in my mind and go through the list
of things I'm not gonna say what you
think I'm gonna say let's see I'll just
say betrayed by the booty that would be
a fun one I'll say betrayed by the booty
because we had that today in our real
lives as we toured New York
some people were betrayed by their booty
[Music]
it would be fantastic of thing hey
Ravens oh I miss him
oh I just left the episode where he ran
behind the pink car being chased after
dogs I was doing research for the new
shop was like oh my goodness Bobby J was
hilarious how's he doing how you doing
[Music]
do I get to sing with Julie Andrews
again Princess Diaries three if I get to
sing with Julie Andrews again that would
be awesome
I mean I'm a Mary Poppins fan so that's
just heaven for me it was spandex from
head to toe and coils in my hair my
first crush during that film not gonna
talk about it anyway moving on it was
great I had a wonderful time with
Kirsten I had a wonderful time with the
people on the set it was cool I had the
best eel sushi Bowl while filming the
first one ever you're welcome
we can only hope to have as many
nostalgic characters come back to Rayven
as home as possible the vision face was
a work in progress for a while between
me my dad and journey and then it just
became real easy and simple
yeah nasty I'd not say you nasty anymore
because it's just it's it's like a
Couture petit Couture word like he
really has to be worthy yes similar
issues will be presented as the seasons
continue as for this season we touch on
some topics but not as in-depth as that
one that isn't up this body shaming we
touch on your first wearing makeup when
you're not supposed to and sealing it
ways of mothering ways of parenting and
and lots of other topics with the kids
but we're gonna dive into the real ones
if we get a second season for sure let's
see my favorite on-screen boyfriend
would have to be Devon only because he
was like my friend too
and we were cool and we worked together
now and we've always kept in touch he's
cool people's he's not like weird it's
okay I like it the cast member I was
closest with would be annalisa
Vanderpool we are still close today we
chilled even after the show ended it was
funny because like I'm this person I
don't text you every day I might not
call you every day you might hear from
me maybe like once a month but that's
because I'm working that's cuz I'm
talking to my mom a half the time and
she understood that so we always had
tabs on each other so I moved here and
she called me she was like you're moving
to New York right here so we had our
moment there we went out a couple times
but we've always taken care of each
other on our off time
I did not improvise that much on that so
Raven in the very beginning as we all
got comfortable with who Raven Baxter
was and I understood the guidelines of
what I could and could not say on theirs
name
there were ad-libs such as you nasty and
oh snap as I go into Ravens home it's
funny because I have to tell the kids
you can't ad-lib yet no like I don't
know just is it worked by promise I ate
it in two but do it so that's just how
it is right now it's fun and I'm trying
my best not to ad-lib they used to call
me aw as written because I just wouldn't
do it and now my memory is real bad
[Music]
and playing a mother there's a you know
I have responsibilities and jobs to hold
and especially on Disney Channel you're
not gonna you know there's there's a big
difference obviously because this is a
Kids program for sure this is about my
twins this is about Chelsea's son and
their next-door neighbor and we just
happen to be the parents but we're still
crazy like we're still teenager ish I
guess we have to say and annalisa and I
are always checking each other say we
have to make sure that we're a parent we
have to make sure we're acting like
parents but it's hard because raven and
chelsea weren't crazy or you had
problems even as adults
how about I do you one better I remember
the lyrics to my first song released on
NCA records when I was five quest I
remember the lyrics that's the right
things up but here's my question to you
do you know the lyrics to the Ravens
home theme song
[Music]